et
[Musique]
oui
c'est justement un attentat
[Musique]
ok
le lendemain de la visite de barack
obama dans la salle de presse
nous nous sommes tous s'installer avec
lui à la maison blanche nos débutants de
washington dans ce monde qui fait rêver
heureux de couvrir cette présidence est
stressé par les demandes constantes de
nos rédactions mais si fiers de vivre
une nouvelle page de l'histoire
le quatrième pouvoir et le bureau ovale
on m'a dit de poser mes affaires ici
dans la salle de presse construite sur
les vestiges de la piscine du président
roosevelt à ma surprise
loin des films d'hollywood chaque média
s'entassent dans des petits bureaux à
l'ecoute de haut parleurs annonçant
l'événement à 37 ans choc todt est le
correspondant de nbc news
il est aussi le chef du service
politique il est basé en permanence à la
maison blanche
il sut obama depuis 2002 il travaille 7
jours sur 7 avec son numéro deux
savannah but pique au total nbcnews
emploie neuf personnes à la maison
blanche
cohabitant dans un bureau de 5 mètres
carrés
cette année nbc news a réalisé plus
d'une dizaine d'interviews d'obama la
méthode est simple être toujours là face
au pouvoir
[Musique]
ici il y à 130 journalistes accrédités
en permanence 29 min bureaux 17 cabines
installées au coeur du système
la salle de presse qui jouxte le bureau
ovale chaque jour chaque tonne et ses
collègues sont assis au premier rang
avec un siège réservé tous les grands
médias américains
ils ont imposé leur plaque ne laissant
personne s'asseoir à leur place au total
il y à 49 places assises
chaque jour aussi les questions au porte
parole robert gibbs sont un test
d'endurance pour l'administration obama
comme ici sur la réforme de santé tandis
que la réforme passera avant la fin de
l'année c'est ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que la loi sur un signe et pas
autre chose n'est-ce pas sérieusement
comment puis-je être plus précis
trouvez vous que ce que je dis est
ambigu c'est le bon deadline alors mais
je viens de répondre à cette question
trois fois le deadline et donc la fin de
l'année 2009 c'est bien ça s'il vous
plaît envoyez ma déclaration pareille
malades chaque pointe à nbc toi et moi
point com
alors ça veut dire quoi et je viens de
répondre à cette question trois fois
trois fois
alors pour ceux qui veulent faire un
flash spécial
le président veut signer la réforme de
la santé avant la fin de l'année des
moments comme ceux là il y en a eu des
dizaines des centaines cette année dans
ces briefings les grands médias se veut
le gardien féroce de la démocratie et
tous reconnaissent que l'accès à
l'information sérieuse n'est pas facile
je pense que maintenant il y à un mur un
mur invisible entre l'équipe de la
maison blanche et la presse est encore
plus qu'avant et je dirais même que du
coup il y à un mur supplémentaires entre
le président et la presse vous savez la
semaine dernière justement on en parlait
dans un club de la presse si on
s'interrogeait sur les relations
personnelles que l'on peut tisser et
pour moi c'est clair je n'aurais jamais
une relation personnelle avec le
président obama comme mes prédécesseurs
ici l'on tue avec gerald ford ou richard
nixon
ça n'arrivera jamais en raison de ce mur
qui a été construit et érigé comment
briser le mur
en arrivant à washington obama avait
promis le changement la transparence une
révolution
cette année sur les sujets sensibles
l'administration n'a rien changé
[Musique]
toute l'année j'ai assisté sur
l'afghanistan à une communication
maîtrisée comme au temps de bush avec
l'irak
un groupe de journalistes et convoquer
un pool géré par ben un jeune bachelier
proche d'obama qui a fait toute sa
campagne en résumant pour lui les
journaux après les avoir vues sur
internet
à 3 heures du matin
m
ben contrôler le pool et n'accorde bien
sûr aucune interview et c'est toujours
lui qui nous escorte vers le président
avec obama souvent je m'attendais à plus
d'accès dans notre quotidien
en fait les visites sont bien gérées
démonstration merci à tous d'être
l'arbre tout à l'heure nous ferons une
déclaration officielle
mais ici je veux simplement vous dire
que la journée a été extrêmement
productive autour de cette table il n'y
a pas que trois présidents mais aussi
des ministres et des responsables des
agences gouvernementales
cela reflète bien la volonté concrète
que nous avons de coopérer jusque dans
les moindres détails
une coopération qui va nous permettre
d'améliorer les choses et surtout de
vrais pour la démocratie et la stabilité
au pakistan et en afghanistan
37 secondes 17 centièmes de transparence
puis la lumière s'éteint le président ne
nous regardent plus nous devons sortir
sans avoir réponse à la moindre question
une heure plus tard la presse est aussi
convié dans la east room une autre aile
de la maison blanche obama avec le
président afghan karzaï veut s'adresser
aux journalistes
là aussi la mise en scène est soignée
ben traits et les contrôles toujours son
monde partout des prompteurs et nous
peuple des médias simples figurants
[Musique]
ouais ça commence
petite explication vous verrez souvent
obama à voir ce mouvement c'est tête à
gauche puis à droite puis à gauche
90% du temps cette première année il n'a
jamais improvisées lisant parfaitement
sur un prompteur un discours préparé par
ses conseillers
[Musique]
oui à la fin pour nous cela donnait
toujours ceux ci aucune possibilité de
poser la moindre question
l'église j'estime qu'il passe beaucoup
trop de temps à la télévision il est
encore plus présent à la télé que jay
leno
l'autre jour il était sur les cinq
émissions politiques du dimanche matin
c'est bien sûr le soir aussi dans tous
les journaux qui s'égare ni vineuse
il accorde beaucoup trop d'interviews
supposé exclusive
il n'est pas rare que cinq ou six
chaînes les le même jour et il ya une
vraie distance contre lui et le peuple
il ne donne l'impression d'être ouvert
accessible
en fait c'est une situation très
contrôlé quelqu'un d'autre jours à
washington me disais que
l'administration obama c'est pareil
qu'au temps de reggane comme reagan de
quelle manière
et bien sûr l'équipe contrôler le
message à faire passer il ne dérape
jamais et n'improvise jamais comme cela
pouvait être le cas sous clinton
c'est une organisation très contrôlés et
très bien verrouillé
[Musique]
alors comme toujours la résistance à ce
contrôle s'organisent les présidents
passent mais les médias sont toujours là
de manière ironique un camp de base
médiatique s'est installé à 10 mètres du
bureau ovale
chaque grande chaîne à son studio en
plein air prêtait tout 24 heures sur 24
les cameramans ils ont même installé
leur transat se relayant pour attendre
ainsi pendant de longues heures la
moindre crise
beaucoup de mes confrères ont refusé
pour ce film d'être suivi préférant se
concentrer sur le président on ne
plaisante pas ici avec le quatrième
pouvoir
avec eux j'ai appris à suivre la
politique 20 heures sur 24 les yeux
rivés sur un écran télé dans une salle
de presse ou sur un blackberry avec la
peur de rater le bon communiqué
comme eux je suis pourtant désormais
accro à la maison blanche
on s'habitue vite à voir un hélicoptère
se poser dans le jardin pour emmener le
président week-end à candé vide
ici on ne se moque jamais de la fonction
présidentielle et au delà de la bonne
image je ne vois plus obama bo cool ou
humain comme mes confrères je cherche
désormais simplement à poser la question
qui dérange
[Musique]
le rejet présidentielle ça fait partie
de la vie courante on s'y habitue vite
alors dans ses bureaux minuscule de
cette salle de presse personne ne se
décourage enchaînés à leur ordinateur
mes confrères comme elle en rit de cnn
cherche sans cesse à bousculer le
pouvoir en place pour ces journalistes
se faire détester fait partie du job
gauche dont je couvrais george bush
il est devenu fou de colère à propos
d'un reportage que j'ai fait sur la cia
leurs méthodes d'interrogatoire et la
torture c'était une grosse histoire et
on posait des questions sans concession
c'était au moment où la cia avait
détruit des cassettes vidéos de ces
interrogatoires et donc les preuves qui
nous auraient permis d'enquêté mais
question mettait le président bush
tellement en colère que lors de la
conférence de presse suivante il ne m'a
jamais donné la parole c'était la
première fois que cnn n'avait pas eu le
droit de poser une question lors d'une
conférence de presse présidentielle
au début j'étais vraiment en colère
parce que tu es là avec les autres tu
n'es pas là que pour toi tu représentes
cnn et si cnn est pénalisé par son
travail et qu'on ne te donne pas la
parole
cela veut dire que si elle ne compte
plus que cnn n'est plus important pour
un président mais après j'ai réfléchi et
je me suis dit qu'en fait c'était comme
une médaille d'honneur parce que si le
président film est tellement en colère à
cause de tout le travail qui est
pourtant précis et impartiale et bien
tant pis sorbet pour ces informations et
d'henri 38 ans va de temps à autre voir
en privé le porte parole du président
obama robert gibbs
lui qui a couvert bouche couvre aussi
obama qu'il a rencontré en 2005 il a
reçu plusieurs distinctions du
journalisme pour son impartialité et au
delà des grands sourires à la moindre
occasion le jeu et de coincer le pouvoir
en place
[Musique]
le général mcchrystal dit de
l'afghanistan que c'est le cas aux east
hants le président trouve-t-il que ce
monde ko distant peut améliorer la
situation je ne sais pas si le président
a vu cela mais votre sentiment à vous
c'est utile je pense que malgré les
sous-entendus de votre question ce ne
sont pas des sous-entendus c'était ses
mots laissez moi laissez moi vous
répondre vous changez ma question il a
bien employer le mot chaos distance
était ce utile
ce que je dis c'est malgré des
sous-entendus de votre question et des
nombreuses rumeurs que la presse
colporte le président croit ce n'est pas
une rumeur s'est fondée il a déclaré
dans un discours
j'ai compris j'ai compris que le jeu à
washington c'était bien de polémique et
j'ai compris cela
casser le jeu de washington
l'establishment une nouvelle presse le
fait volontairement installé dans la
banlieue de washington
un site fait désormais trembler l'élite
politico créé il ya quatre ans par des
anciens journalistes du washington post
leur but une information instantanée
avec un site politico 44 un journal
minute par minute de la présidence
d'obama le 44e président américain
vidéos photos et emploi du temps c'est
le suivi instantanée de tout ce que fait
le chef de l'état politico emploie huit
reporters permanent à la maison blanche
et des blogueurs qui de chez eux peuvent
aussi rapporter tout événement
concernant l'administration obama
avec un budget limité politico fait
chaque jour l'événement pour le plus
grand plaisir de son rédacteur en chef
[Musique]
on est arrivé à un stade où la manière
dont la politique est couverte et se
pratique change de manière radicale cela
fait trente ans que je couvre la
politique quand j'ai débuté on
m'envoyait couvrir un discours
et puis je rentrais j'écrivais mon
article et c'était publié le lendemain
dans le journal aujourd'hui
ce n'est même plus la peine d'essayer de
comparer la dernière campagne les
boucles d'infos traditionnel des chaînes
câblées était totalement dépassé on est
passé à une un fou dans la durée de vie
est de 6 à 8 heures seulement elle
démarre le matin et à la mi journée soit
elle est déjà caduc
soit elles se retrouvent sur les blogs
soit elle grossit pour devenir une autre
histoire
et ce dès lors du déjeuner le jour même
vous savez aujourd'hui les gens veulent
consommer de l'info exactement comme ils
reçoivent leurs sms
de la même manière qu'ils utilisent
twitter ou facebook
on doit s'adapter à ce nouveau monde
barack obama a tout compris à la
nouvelle information avec son équipe il
a décidé de miser là dessus pour la
première fois cette année le peuple
américain a donc eu le droit de poser
des questions directement via youtube au
président opérations de communication
qui fait grincer bien des dents dans le
monde très classique de la politique us
mbk des méchas jazz notre président n'a
mis au point ce que le président obama
essaye de faire avec internet
mais en faisant cela remet il essaye
aussi de court circuiter la presse
traditionnelle
les magazines les quotidiens les radios
les chaînes de télé il veut passer au
dessus de leurs têtes et parler
directement au peuple autant que
possible ce n'est pas juste de leur
parler sa communication est tout entière
basée là-dessus sa stratégie aussi c'est
une idée toute simple d'esprit
nous allons utiliser un autre avantage
la presse traditionnelle qui n'est plus
comme autrefois le vecteur le plus
important de notre communication
bon je te pose aujourd'hui le plus
efficace pour communiquer avec les gens
c'est de passer à travers l'internet et
en leur parlant directement la magie de
la communication peut aussi se retourner
contre le président au printemps dernier
barack obama a débarqué dans notre salle
il voulait parler de l'iran aujourd'hui
je vais vous parler de trois problèmes
et ensuite je répondrai à vos questions
d'abord je voudrais vous dire quelques
mots sur la situation en iran je sais
que nico pitney et l'adieu à filton
pause nico je sais que vous suivez
toutes les infos qui nous arrivent via
internet diront et nous aussi
je sais qu'il pourrait y avoir des
questions venant du peuple iranien qui
communique sur internet
vous avez une question oui absolument je
voulais saisir cette opportunité pour
vous faire part de quelques questions
que se posent certains iraniens
ceux qui ont encore le courage de
communiquer sur le net
un homme voulez-vous demander la chose
suivante sous quelles conditions
accepteriez-vous l'élection
d'ahmadinejad et si vous l'acceptez sans
d'importants changements significatifs
n'est ce pas une trahison par rapport à
tout ce que font les manifestants
justement nous n'avions pas
d'observateurs internationaux sur le
terrain et nous ne pouvons rien dire sur
ce qui s'est passé dans les bureaux de
vote à travers le pays bonne réponse du
président mais aussi de ce jeune homme
nico pitney le lendemain le très sérieux
washington post révèle que nico pitney
s'est fait payer son voyage par la
maison blanche pour venir poser sa
question titre le obama show en fait une
vengeance de la presse traditionnelle
[Musique]
alors le lendemain face à la colère de
l'establishment médiatique le porte
parole confirme que ses méthodes de
communication sont désormais la marque
de fabrique de barack obama
je pense que c'était important et le
président pense aussi que c'était
important de prendre une question issus
des sources qui ont utilisé tous pour
faire circuler les informations je ne
vais pas m'excuser pour cela au make any
prend au juste
l'une des gardiennes du temple de
l'éthique journalistique
helen thomas à la maison blanche elle a
couvert tous les présidents depuis
kennedy et la politique américaine
depuis 1945
non
e
hélène je laime j'adore sa passion pour
la non compromission
elle m'a éduqué en me donnant sa règle
on ne ment pas et on résiste au pouvoir
alors le jour de ses 89 ans j'étais là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attendu deux ans
et berlin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hélène elle ne s'arrête jamais c'est une
institution à washington
je les ai suivis dans sa routine et
parfois c'est honneur au club de la
presse de la capitale où elle a présenté
à plus de 89 ans son dernier ouvrage
elle seconde boucle
why did you might be
pas mal
benoît hamon
m
les salles
croisière
sma
je m'excuse
[Rires]
des journalistes aux hommes politiques
hélène adore qu'on fait c'est tout le
monde comme ici le sénateur du texas
henry waxman qui a fait voter la loi
anti tabac aux états unis
le gala
comme ça
elle n'aime pas perdre son temps hélène
et
les aînés se touchent
bonne idée
fond
contre la copie de la liste
unisyn ce monsieur
avec helen thomas ce j'ai appris que la
persévérance paye
[Musique]
comme elle il faut rester de longues
heures à la maison blanche
et là tout peut arriver 24 heures sur 24
ceux qui ont les scoops sont ceux qui
sont là tout le temps une nuit je suis
resté tard après 15 heures passées là et
devant le bureau ovale j'ai eu un choc
je n'ai comme obama ne voulait pas
d'image pour leur rencontre alors en
pensant à hélène thomass j'ai tenté la
question dérangeante
avez vous un deadline pour le darfour tu
as mines
il est prêt clooney pour la politique il
répond avec un grand sourire une petite
blague va bien faire son direct sur cnn
un petit tour et puis rien cloud nine si
c'était un soir
le lendemain à la maison blanche on
l'avait déjà oublié
[Musique]
du darfour à l'irak pendant un an la
maison blanche a dû gérer avec nous
toutes les crises
ici personne ne pense aux vacances comme
on me l'a dit le monde en guerre ne dort
jamais alors la machine doit rester tout
le temps éveillée
nadia est correspondante à la maison
blanche depuis huit ans pour la chaîne
arabe mbc seul journaliste palestinienne
accrédités en permanence veuve mère de
deux enfants elle couvre avec passion
washington comme d'autres journalistes
étrangers elles se basent souvent contre
la discrimination
m
d
dans le jardin des roses en cette fin
juillet le président obama doit
rencontrer le premier ministre irakien
maliki
la presse américaine est à gauche avec
des sièges réservés
le reste du monde à droite avec la
meilleure place pour le premier arrivé
à cette petite conférence de presse on a
attendu le président en retard comme
souvent avec devant le bureau ovale les
photographes parqué dans un coin et
leurs appareils télécommandée à distance
pour capter la meilleure image on
regarde toujours obama avec autant
d'attention et on attend qu'il nous
donne aussi la parole pour poser une
question
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président je
m'interroge suite à vos déclarations sur
le fait que les troupes américaines
restent en irak depuis que les irakiens
ont repris le contrôle des villes le
gouvernement irakien ne cessent
d'imposer aux américains des règles pour
contrôle et patrouillé avec eux avez
vous discuté de cela avec le premier
ministre maliki
avez vous exprimer votre désaccord ou
s'agit-il pour vous du signe que les
irakiens reprennent le contrôle de leur
vie barack obama face à cette question
sera alors une réponse selon de deux
minutes 11 secondes sur la situation en
généralisant sur la politique américaine
en irak
la violence a baissé la coopération
entre les forces américaines et
irakiennes reste importante et nous
sommes confiants quant à la poursuite de
notre travail en commun mais il faut
faire les réajustements nécessaires pour
s'assurer qu'avant les élections
nationales
l'irak soit bien sur le chemin de la
stabilité politique et que les forces de
sécurité irakiennes soient de plus en
plus capables de maintenir l'ordre et
donc à un moment nous pourrons atteindre
notre objectif qui est de retirer toutes
nos troupes de l'irak
dès que ce pays aura retrouvé sa
souveraineté il n'y aura que deux
questions dans cette conférence de
presse une américaine pour barack obama
et une accordé à un journaliste irakien
venant de bagdad
et comme toujours il faut s'habituer à
un président qui repart vite s'enfermer
dans son bureau
vous
point du tout faux car je le trouve trop
centré sur lui ils devraient dialoguer
un peu plus avec la presse je ne suis
vraiment pas satisfaite je dois faire un
reportage
et cela fait deux heures que j'attends
sous le soleil pour rien il ne m'a même
pas regarder et vous avez vu on était à
peine à quelques centimètres de lui il
ne nous a même pas vu c'est bizarre non
pendant des mois nadia aura travaillé
tous ses contacts à la maison blanche
des heures des semaines avant le premier
voyage officiel du président dans le
monde arabe
elle n'aura eu aucune réponse à ses
demandes d'interview pourtant elle n'est
pas une débutante reporter de guerre en
somalie et au proche orient
elle a ensuite débarqué il ya quinze ans
à washington elle a interviewé deux fois
le président bush est aujourd'hui très
découragés par la nouvelle
administration
endesa je sais que c'est administration
n'aime pas beaucoup la comparaison mais
je dirais que de manière très
surprenante
j'avais plus facilement accès à mon
chien cas obama et je m'attendais à
linverse parce que durant la campagne
obama n'a cessé de dire qu'il fallait
plus de transparence plus d'ouverture
qu'il fallait changer washington
alors évidemment nous on s'attendait à
beaucoup plus d'ouverture de leur part
et malheureusement ce n'est pas le cas
j'espère que cela va changer
d'ailleurs il commence à y avoir des
changements
on doit le reconnaître ce la bataille
d'europe d'ici à la fin de l'année
prochaine souhaitons que l'accès sera
meilleure et qu'on pourra enfin
travailler
m
[Musique]
pourtant la première interview du
président a été accordée à une chaîne
arabe et pour sa première sortie au
proche orient
la maison blanche a choisi l'arabie
saoudite
[Musique]
après 13 heures d'avion l'amérique
débarque
[Musique]
pour un an
à quelques heures d'intervalle à riyad
la capitale du pays
trois avions air force fret air force
presse et art force one arrive souvent
celle qu'on surnomme la bête
la limousine présidentielle est
transporté 24 heures plus tôt pendant
que le chef de l'état descend pour la
photo officielle
tous ces conseillers sorte par l'arrière
d'air force one
trente personnes minimum
dans l'avion obama aura reçu une petite
fiche lui indiquant les noms des
personnes à l'arrivée aucune erreur de
protocole n'est autorisée en une minute
20 secondes
j'ai calculé qu obama aura donc ici
serrer la main de 30 prince du royaume
et 10 militaires
[Musique]
derrière ce protocole fort mal
respectées par tous les conseillers de
barack obama une chose d'ubuesque en
arabie saoudite
compte tenu de la brièveté du séjour
moins de dix heures sur place la maison
blanche nous a fait entrer sans visa
[Musique]
du coup je découvre que les vitres de
nos bus de presse sont toutes masques et
de l'arabie saoudite
je ne verrai donc que cela
m
serait ce pas
on a dormi deux heures ici pas le temps
de faire autre chose que travailler
en plein milieu de la nuit le porte
parole robert gibbs est arrivé pour nous
donner en avant première les grandes
idées du discours du caire avec en
vedette à ses côtés ben rhodes
26 ans le jeune stratège qui monte chez
obama
il est diplômé d'une maîtrise de
littérature et fiction romancier à ses
heures c'est lui qui a écrit le discours
du caire
[Musique]
comment le président at il préparé ce
discours vous savez le président pense à
ce discours depuis très longtemps
il a consulté des gens de tous les
horizons dans notre pays des experts et
d'autres son discours va être surtout ce
qu'il pense depuis des années vous savez
le rien est nouveau pour lui barack
obama c'est un homme de conviction qui a
de la suite dans les idées alors son
discours de demain reflétera avant tout
ce qu'il pense depuis longtemps sur les
arabes cela commencera tignes par salam
aleikoum
[Musique]
départ dans la nuit
arrivé à 5h du matin en egypte par
sécurité les services secrets ne veulent
pas que la caravane américaine passe une
nuit au caire
nous sommes donc arrivés à l'aube
heureux d'apercevoir d'hublot les
pyramides
oh
on aura été briefé sur le rapprochement
des cultures dans la réalité le caire 23
millions d'habitants attend obama
ainsi en état de siège
en choisissant l'université du caire la
maison blanche voulait comme lors de la
campagne présidentielle des jeunes une
belle image une communication bien pensé
obama applaudi par la jeunesse arabe en
liesse mais en egypte
le public se compose ici d'intellectuels
de plus de 50 ans avec souvent les
étudiants au poulailler
comme toujours robert gibbs viendra
vérifier la scène avec reggie
l'assistant d'obama dans une loge les
plus proches
tous les stratèges sont là
et dont le public loin d'eux je remarque
la grande rivale de la campagne hillary
clinton aujourd'hui secrétaire d'état
obama aura répété son discours
travailler tard dans la nuit avec la
volonté de changer sa relation au monde
arabe
il a tout lu sur son prompteur et n'a
jamais improvisées
[Applaudissements]
merci merci beaucoup
bonjour je suis honoré d'être dans cette
ville éternelle du caire et d'être
accueilli par deux institutions aussi
remarquable depuis plus de mille ans
l'une est la référence du monde
islamique en matière de connaissance
depuis un siècle autres cette université
permet le progrès dans le monde égyptien
ensemble vous représentez l'harmonie
entre la tradition et la modernité
je vous suis reconnaissant pour votre
hospitalité ainsi que pour l'hospitalité
du peuple égyptien et je suis fier de
vous présenter ici les voeux du peuple
américain
des voeux de paix de la part des
communautés musulmanes vivant dans mon
pays
[Applaudissements]
être là bas n'a rien apporté de plus
honnêtement à part décrire l'ambiance et
être à ses côtés
je n'ai rien fait de plus que je
n'aurais pu faire en restant assise ici
à mon bureau de washington au caire on
n'a pas eu de réunion après ce discours
je n'ai même pas été admise lors de sa
rencontre avec les journalistes
égyptiens
je n'ai pas une interview avec lui et ça
normalement c'est la tradition
quant à président va dans une partie du
monde
il donne une interview surtout à
quelqu'un comme moi qu'il accompagne
partout et qui suit la maison blanche
depuis six ans j'espérais vraiment qu'il
allait me parler et ça ne s'est pas
passé le voyage nous a coûté beaucoup
d'argent pour le suivre on a dépensé 15
mille dollars voire plus d'un mois et
pour quel résultat
du coup nos rédacteurs en chef au proche
orient ont commencé à calculer
l'investissement en me disant tu as quoi
pour ce prix là on a tous décidé hélas
que désormais je ne voyagerai plus avec
lui sauf si j'ai un meilleur accès à lui
il a changé la communication
présidentielle pour le monde entier
on peut même se demander s'il est devenu
le président des états unis où le
président du monde extrêmement confiance
en sa manière de communiquer non
seulement aux américains mais au reste
du monde bateau d'ailleurs regardez son
histoire personnelle
il a vécu longtemps à l'étranger c'est
une personne de la globalisation autant
qu'il est américain
ces valeurs sont vraiment américaine il
n'a cessé de rassurer les américains là
dessus pendant sa campagne
mais il ya aussi un facteur très
important dans la manière dont la maison
blanche gère la communication avec le
reste du monde
son équipe pensent qu'obama est le
meilleur porte parole du monde pour
l'amérique
sa façon de représenter l'amérique doit
permettre aux autres pays de mieux nous
comprendre et de mieux nous apprécier
toute leur stratégie de communication
est donc centré sur le président
barack obama est-il le président du
monde depuis son élection en un an il
aura visité 28 pays et rencontré des
dizaines de premier ministre et
président
[Musique]
dans ses voyages face à la cadence
infernale les journalistes accrédités de
la maison blanche le voit 80% du temps
sur l'écran grâce à un circuit interne
le pool de la maison blanche
l'enfermement dans ce qu'on appelle la
bulle est totale chacun reste confiné
dans des salles de presse au rideau
souvent fermées par sécurité
[Musique]
les repas avec les décalages horaires se
prennent n'importe quoi la maison
blanche prévoit tout est nourri ses
troupes
24 heures sur 24
know and treat pour comprendre notre
rythme en moins de 48 heures nous aurons
par exemple fait 22 heures d'avion et
trois pays
[Musique]
en allemagne par manque de temps la
maison blanche ne voulait pas nous
déplacer d'une ville à l'autre
alors nous avons regardé sur circuit
interne
la majorité des déplacements d'obama
specter m6 et
en allemagne choc todt est venue avec
ses deux journalistes
nbcnews aura ici envoyé huit personnes
dont tom brooke aux stars de la chaîne
qui aura réalisé une interview d'obama
tom brooke aura vie qui confie aux
troupes ces derniers potins
à quoi
[Musique]
axa hockey honnêtement aa
après avoir écouté les anecdotes des
stars le travail à la mine reprend
combien de direct par jour faites vous
pour la chaîne d'info continue leur
demande c'est un flash par heure on en a
fait 15 aujourd'hui
il imagine qu'un sur une journée de 12
heures c'est dingue réfléchi deux
secondes
comment te procure tu les infos si tu
dois faire un direct par heure ça veut
dire cinq minutes minimum devant la
caméra
finalement il ne te reste que 50 minutes
pour avoir les bonnes infos aller aux
toilettes manger appelé tes enfants
c'est dingue
[Musique]
la chose que je préfère et on en
plaisante beaucoup avec mon rival de six
billets c'est que toutes les grandes
visites touristiques on les fait à trois
heures du matin au moment où on a plus
de directs alors on a été sur la place
rouge à trois heures du matin et aussi à
l'arc de triomphe on a d'ailleurs été
expulsé il y avait des gardes près de la
flamme et nous on dit faute et canche à
mai c'est notre seule chance de visiter
avec le rythme d'info continue et le
décalage horaire voir ses monuments
c'est forcément à 3h du mat
sur ce voyage où barack obama visite le
camp de concentration de buchenwald
nous ne pouvons le voir qu'à sa
conférence de presse nous avons dû
arriver
comme souvent trois heures avant et
pendant cette attente pas question pour
un correspondant américain de la maison
blanche d'arrêter de travailler
[Musique]
mais ni même combien de mails par jour
recevez-vous en période de vacances
genre soit 6 cents par jour
et si je commence à y répondre j'en ai
alors trois mille par jour 3000 emails
par jour
oui je le pense mais c'est parce que je
commence à répondre et d'un seul coup il
y en allant des milliers personnes très
important non la plupart ce sont des
trucs nul je reçois par exemple 25 email
par heure d'attaché de presse me
demandant de faire passer des experts en
tout genre à la télé
rien que cela ça représente 20 à 25 mail
par heure pour des profs d'université
des experts des sondeurs et ça fait 3
400 emails par jour
à combien d'expéditeurs vous répondait
immédiatement
je dis toujours aux gens si tu m'envoies
un mail deux heures avant le jt
t'es sûr dans ces deux heures de ne
jamais recevoir ma réponse mais il y à
un certain moment où je me coince des
fenêtres de tir pour simplement répondre
à tous les maires
côté européen on est moins stakhanoviste
qu'est ce qui vous surprend le plus dans
ce voyage
c'est un peu la lourdeur
c'est justement sur 1
voilà sur l'étape allemande
la chose intéressante c'est quand même
d'aller à buchenwald
vous qui bavent ici
libéré et c'est quelque chose qui se
passe des mouvances veut dire quelque
chose on y va mais reçoit
on est quoi ca dre
200 km2
qu'est ce qu'ils ont nié
même par mes propres moyens soit pas
rentrée bonté
hier c'est un peu pareil bon évidemment
le discours
enfin la visite aux pyramides c'est
aussi la couleur
il a raconté
on est grands traits
prisonnier de l'ordre
[Musique]
obama at il conscience de notre
enfermement
impossible à savoir j'ai noté en tout
cas que le président compose à merveille
son rôle de chef d'état et nous
regardent de moins en moins souvent en
face
[Musique]
quand c'est là-bas
noir le par
[Musique]
on sait
bah
cohen
mamba
au pas
oh
howe
[Musique]
à
plus
ce
le président est arrivé au ghana en
juillet en pleine nuit dans la capitale
où souvent par manque d'électricité
le peuple ne sort pas à la rédaction de
tv 3 la télévision nationale du pays
toute la rédaction s'est mobilisé pour
faire des émissions spéciales sur obama
attendu comme le messie par les
journalistes et la directrice de
l'information
on a demandé 17 accréditation pour 17
journalistes combien d'accréditation
avez vous reçu on en a reçu seulement 2
way 2 nous étions en colère
oui j'étais très en colère j'ai appelé
le ministère de l'information et je lui
ai dit tu sais quoi
on a un travail à faire et on nous
empêche de le faire le public n'aura pas
la couverture médiatique que vous
attendez pour la venue du président
américain au ghana
c'est la première fois que je fais cela
j'étais vraiment en colère
énervé et déçu fait tous les services
auxquels les masses se sont adressés
sont restés inflexibles pas plus de deux
accréditations pour la télé du ghana
l'ambassade américaine sur place n'a
jamais répondu aux dizaines de demandes
d'interviews du président
l'ambassadeur a même refusé de venir en
invité parler de la visite
qu'importe une nuit spéciale s'est
organisée avec aux premières loges une
jeune et ravissante présentatrice au
ghana la bimbo journalistes ça marche
aussi
les deux lots et visite des pensions
juste vraiment le haut à tours let's not
c'était ça prend une semaine
[Musique]
ablynx marque toile et marcia cross et
johan beerlandt emilio noda parce que
tout le monde respecte thing he has done
for pour parrot by night day you will i
am in swing band se voir priver malus de
n'avoir moi qui me le suis à los angelès
par washington
[Musique]
le pool américain arrivé quelques heures
plus tôt en voit comme toujours au monde
entier les images filmées par la seule
caméra accrédités ça c'est l'image
envoyée par le pool américain seul petit
problème il y aura une erreur technique
les gagnants verront donc en direct
l'arrivée du président sur le continent
noir uniquement en verre comme si des
martiens démarquait
il est à la traîne 10 12 le ghana a dû
se caler sur le système rigide mise en
place par la maison blanche
pas facile de s'adapter à la
communication globale
[Musique]
comme toujours le pool nous livrera
aussi quelques secondes d'intimité
d'obama
puis pendant 12 heures sur place il sera
enfermée dans son hôtel bunker interdit
bien sûr à la presse et au peuple
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
journalistes à la maison blanche
c'est aussi suivre chaque chose à la
vitesse du président on voir le monde en
ultra rapide
les visages des peuples en clips des
peuples au cri qu'on n'entend jamais
on est toujours en mouvement ou derrière
un écran une vitre sécurité départ
arrêts alors au rythme du zapping du
voyage
on rate aucune occasion
dawa
l'acquis de monitor
deux questions et ça repart il est
ensuite ce temps d'attentes entre notre
arrivée et celui du chef de l'état
alors entre deux portes on essaye de se
faire copain copain avec le staff
le contact virtuel enfin remplacé par de
l'humain
sur ce genre de voyages à l'étranger ont
fait partie de la même équipe
alors c'est plus simple les barrières
tombent un peu on est à l'autre bout du
monde on pose toujours des questions un
peu dur mais on se serre les coudes on
est tous dans la même galère on est dans
un pays étranger
on a tous pris le même médicament contre
la malaria et on a tous les mêmes effets
secondaires on est juste des bons
américains qui voyagent ensemble choc
tod sur ce voyage aura dormi trois
heures par nuit
la fatigue se lit sur tous les visages
et surtout ceux du pool ses treize
journalistes qui depuis l'aube
suivent de près obama au ghana
[Musique]
choc todt lui doit enchaîner avec son
équipe les plateaux en situation à ses
côtés athéna jones a produit soeur et
son cameraman qui selon la charte des
chaînes américaines doit tout contrôler
dans la politesse absolue
puis très vite silence la mobilisation
de nbc est générale l'équipe d'obama
vient d'envoyer un email
[Musique]
oh oui
moi
ans
[Musique]
oh
à
mais on voit ce troisième à trois la
même taille pour la tête
j'ai souvent été frappé par l'attitude
d'obama lorsqu'on évoque devant lui
qu'il est le premier président noir
américain
ils restent calmes sûr de lui mettre de
six émotions sourire au point et pour
nous tous au-delà de cette image
obama en afrique ce sera aussi se
souvenir
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
non
on aura je vous le confesse tous garder
ce voyage du ghana comme un moment un
peu spécial dans notre année de folie
yes we can hymne de la campagne
présidentielle
repris en choeur par les africains et
puis ce beau sourire de barack obama
enfin retrouver ce sourire d'un chef
d'état noir sur le continent africain
[Musique]
rooney cameraman a fait pour nbc plus de
50 voyages présidentiels depuis 20 ans
pour la première fois ici le krach en
voyant obama son président noir en
afrique
[Musique]
mr
merde
ans
m
[Applaudissements]
santé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas le temps non plus ici pour des
arrêts sur l'émotion mais des mois plus
tard l'équipe de nbc parle encore de ce
moment de vie
[Musique]
souvent dans cette administration jeune
j'ai remarqué qu'à chaque grande
occasion chacun s'en donnent à coeur
joie
j'ai adoré par exemple lors de la fête
d'halloween à la maison blanche le porte
parole robert gibbs en dark vador
[Musique]
et puis une surprise non
à
m
il adore blagué obama c'est là où il est
le meilleur en improvisant toute l'année
j'ai remarqué aussi qui s'est toujours
prêter de bonne humeur à son succès
médiatique
à peine arrivée la présentation de son
chien bo fut un événement digne des
oscars d'hollywood
à
finalement au delà de l'aspect
hystérique on retiendra l'image d'une
belle famille qui sans manières se plier
à la règle du vedettariat
[Musique]
au fil des mois cette famille obama
s'est d'ailleurs bien habitué à vivre
avec nous les observons en permanence de
la maison blanche à leurs vacances
on les suit tout le temps avec nous
attendant impitoyablement le faux-pas
lagaf' la crise le sourire ou la petite
phrase du moment
[Musique]
je
alors une règle secrète cet institut est
on est là ils le savent conscient qu'à
ce poste-là tout moment privé appartient
toujours au peuple américain
le système de la maison blanche est
parfait dans cette organisation
[Musique]
le président est un habitué des médias
il ne nous regardent plus jamais comme
si nous étions invisible
je tiens
m
non
dans chaque opération
la maison blanche n'hésite pas à
fabriquer de la communication avec tous
les outils qu'il a en sa possession est
aussi souvent que cela est nécessaire
pour être efficace ce serait naïf de
penser autrement sauf lorsqu'on en vient
à parler de sa famille la famille
d'obama c'est bien une famille une vraie
famille et c'est aussi pour cela que
dans la communication ça marche si bien
ce n'est pas fabriqué c'est une vraie
famille unie pour tout le reste
en terme d'image ou de message à faire
passer ils utilisent très bien les
autres outils mieux je veux tout ce que
la maison blanche obama a inventé c'est
le publireportage exemple j'ai demandé à
faire un sujet sur les quarante mille
lettres que le président reçoit chaque
jour on m'a alors conseillé de tout
télécharger sur mon ordinateur un sujet
entièrement réalisée par la cellule de
com sur le postier d'hobart à extraire
[Musique]
ce travail nous parlons évidemment les
journalistes que je suis ne plus jamais
interviewé le postier
il se contente d'avoir le plaisir de
regarder le président qui se raconte ici
de manière intime
j'ai reçu une très belle lettre d'une
dame celle que son père lui avait envoyé
alors qu'il était soldat pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale elle venait de
naître et son père venait de l'apprendre
alors qu'il était au front
dans cette lettre il lui écrit ma chérie
je veux tu expliquer ce que je fais ici
et pourquoi ce combat est si important
pour toi ton pays un jour tu seras en
âge de comprendre lorsqu'on reçoit ce
genre de lettre ça vous conforte dans ce
qu'il y a de meilleur dans l'amérique ça
vous inspire
et savoure en force dans votre volonté
de travailler très dur pour le bien du
pays
dans le couple rassurez vous il n'y a
pas de rivalité dont les publi reportage
produit entièrement pour internet
michelle obama l axe son image sur son
petit potager botanique tout conçu à la
manière
d'un joli sitcom
dans les rôles des comédiens les
cuisiner bio de la maison blanche
[Musique]
comme pour un bon sujet de news le gros
plan sur les salades et bien là michelle
obama elle réserve ses confessions à ce
publireportage avec son chemisier
assorti au décor alors après une année
comme celle ci j'ai retenu un vrai
moment fort qu'on ne fabrique pas et qui
me fait toujours aimé mon travail auprès
d'obama
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'était à new york à l'automne dernier
c'était un enterrement celui de walter
cancre ait la star absolue de cbs news
conques wright du vietnam à l'assassinât
de kennedy
il a tout fait tout vu tout dit en face
au peuple américain
incarnant un journalisme pur dur loin du
people à son enterrement au premier rang
et murs regardant ses archives sur sa
vie il y avait bill clinton et barack
obama obama a voulu nous parler nous les
reporter cameraman preneur de son
monteur chef d'infos rédacteur en chef
directeur de rédaction
pratique on était tous là pour walter
q
que
greg wood
quand même
à travers tous les événements qui ont
défini le 20e siècle
ces moments de profonde douleur et de
grands espoirs
walter cronkite a toujours été là pour
raconter la mairie c'est la manière dont
nous nous souvenons de lui aujourd'hui
mais je veux aussi me rappeler est
honorée avec vous les grandes valeurs du
journalisme que walter défendeur des
valeurs d'honnêteté d'intégrité et de
responsabilité des valeurs que vous avez
tous ici choisi d'embrasser dans votre
métier
des valeurs qui sont de plus en plus
durs à trouver aujourd'hui je sais que
les temps sont durs pour le journalisme
sérieux malgré un appétit grandissant du
public pour la formation et l'actualité
chaude les rédactions ferment les unes
après les autres
malgré les innombrables événement
d'importance
les journalistes ont de plus en plus de
mal à les couvrir
au moment où l'info est en perte de
vitesse
le journalisme sérieux rasent les murs
trop souvent cela est remplacé par des
commentaires instantanée des potins sur
la vie privée des people
toutes ces infos que walter détestait et
qui remplace le journalisme
d'investigation qui lui était si cher
aujourd'hui on s'intéresse plus vraiment
à ce qui se passe mais à qui a fait la
meilleure audience le niveau de la faune
ne cesse de diminuer la confiance du
public est altérée nous échouons dans
notre mission d'informer sur le monde et
cela devrait conséquences sur nos vies
et dans la vie de notre pays
c'est pourquoi les reportages honnête
objectif les sujets méticuleux que vous
faites et que walter défend des sons si
vitaux pour notre démocratie et notre
société un pitch de notre avenir dépend
de sol allemand
[Musique]
oui il fut longuement applaudie obama ce
jour-là par nous victime de notre métier
en voie de disparition
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors au bout d'un moment chacun dans
cette salle c'est aussi redonner du
baume au coeur après ces mots si
romantique d'un président sur notre
profession choc todd m'a confié que dans
dix ans il se voit en train d'écrire des
livres et de continuer pour le bien de
la démocratie à décrypter les actions
des politiciens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
helen thomas held en dix ans espère
qu'elle posera toujours là où elle sort
à la question qui dérange
nadia elle veut changer de camp elle
veut devenir quelques années maire de
ramallah et m'a bien sûr promis le full
access pour sa campagne
et d'ombrie après avoir parce les tous
les porte parole de la maison blanche
m'a confié espérer travailler dans dix
ans pour canal+ et vivre en europe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quant à moi j'espère qu'obama mort a
accordé sa 100ème interview en
exclusivité pour canal+
et si ce n'est pas possible comme
d'habitude j'essayerai simplement de
faire mon métier sans trop de compromis
[Musique]
obama lui dans dix ans je ne sais pas je
n'ai pas encore vérifié comme on dit à
la maison blanche
j'espère qu'il écoutera toujours du jazz
et défendra le journalisme sérieux avec
passion
[Musique]
ans
tout ça
[Musique]
à
en bas
on va
aux parents
oh
[Musique]